Mark Steyn is an author and columnist
and the subject of many attacks online
since his last appearance on the show
including I think on joy reads program
over the weekend so we thought he'd
invite him back and ask him for a
response hey do mark hey I'm doing great
Tucker fascinated to hear about your
great-grandfather from Switzerland in
1860 it's it's interesting to me that
well capture some of the things well
yeah one of the things I like about you
taco what are though what are the few
things is that you don't when you
discuss immigration you don't go on
about your great-grandfather and it's
interesting to me that because because
most people say oh well you know people
people attack immigration my
great-grandmother got off the boat at
Ellis Island in 1979 and six weeks later
she was the third orphan on the right in
the Broadway production of Annie singing
The Sun will come out tomorrow and
that's the American dream right there I
either do that they either do that or
they say well you know I've got a
venezuelan pool boy and he's the
hardest-working chap i though so what's
the problem with immigration and and in
fact you're the only one because you're
one of the few people who doesn't
discuss it in terms of your
great-grandfather MSNBC has hired
somebody to find out who your
great-grandfather is and hang him round
your neck and as you pointed out this is
completely preposterous we've gotten
there were lots of things we needed in
1860 your great-grandfather
buggy whips the Transcontinental
Railroad oxen and oddly enough a hundred
and sixty years later we need less of
all those things apparently except
immigration this is absurd well what's
so interesting is how there's no real
response other than to the personal I
mean I I know the temptation when you
get upset about something to try and
hang it on a person's personal hang-ups
or his personality errs background
whatever but but you try to pull back
and ask what principles are at stake
here and ask obvious questions like how
does this help the Americans already
here I cannot get I'm not just saying
this every night I cannot get a real
answer to that from anybody ever not one
Oh No
well it is this resistance to talking
about in public policy I had something
similar after I was on your show last
week there's all these people who are
suddenly going online and and pointing
out that I'm Canadian it was the first
I'd heard of it I was stunned the MS the
MSNBC genealogists have been in touch
with the vital statistics office in the
Dominion of Canada
I was stuck the fact is its public
policy
I go to Rosengard in Sweden and what I
see there I think is a tragedy for the
Swedes will be an ethnic minority in
their own country by mid-century
I go to molenbeek in my mother's country
of Belgium and I think that's a tragedy
and actually just to save the MSNBC
house genealogists a bit of time I'm
going to be an Irish Belgian Canadian
which is one of the smaller parades down
Main Street every year every year but
there's in the scheme of things
they were very there of is very little
difference between Irish Catholics and
Irish Protestants yet that is caused
tragic bloodshed in our lifetime there
is very little difference in the scheme
of things between francophone Quebecers
a half hour north of me here in northern
New England and Anglophone Canadians yet
twenty years ago in the 1990s a majority
of francophone Quebecers voted that they
didn't want to be part of the same
country as Canadians and so smiley so
putting aside race small group
differences can have huge consequences
and that's why I can make a point I make
a lot on your show Tucker that when
you're talking about public policy it's
best to err on the side of prudence and
if we can and the Democrats all the time
or about how as we've just established
with joy Reid it's not that you can't
talk about this subject it's just that
as joy sees it only certain people can
do so she can say the Democrats should
give up on white rural voters and just
focus on black voters Kirsten powers
Democrat can say on election night 2012
that this is about the Browning of
America Bob Beckel on election night can
another Democrat can talk about the
white vote so what joy and Co is saying
is that basically those they can talk
about it incessantly but just that
nobody else can yeah I'd rather not play
by those rules so we're not going to
another you know why we love you Mark
Steyn thank you and it's and it's not in
good faith Tucker which is what your
show in fairness is well thanks I
appreciate that good to see you